liebe zuschauer freuen sie sich auch
schon so auf ihren friseur termin am
ersten märz endlich wieder aussehen wie
mensch bei mir sind alle strähnchen
rausgewachsen nach über fünf stunden
sitzung beschließen angela merkel und
die länder fürsten am mittwoch genau
eine konkrete maßnahme friseure auf
sonst eigentlich nichts das war um es
mit einem klassischen friseurladen
wortspiel zu sagen nur kreativ und
vorhersehbar der rest ist einfach nur
locker und verlängerung ende
wie erkläre ich einzelhändlern dass sie
trotz hygiene konzept zu bleiben während
die dauerwellen dealer auf haben frisch
frisierte deutsche warten vielleicht
etwas weniger wütend auf ihren
impftermin oder was war hier das motiv
auch die friseure die ich übrigens als
teil von ja nicht nur hygiene sondern
auch schon würde betrachte auch für
viele menschen diese schwierigen zeit
das gehört zur elementaren körper
körperpflege dazu dass das ähnlich zu
betrachten ist wie eine eine
psychologische versorgung wer schneidet
denn eigentlich ihnen die haare lindner
hat bundeskanzlerin merkel hat sich um
ihre frisur friseure friseure die
friseure für viele menschen betrifft es
fast ihre körperliche gesundheit ja klar
an sonne unbehandelten spliss da kannst
du sterben
friesinger ist wie arzt natürlich könnte
man den friseure und friseurinnen das
comeback sei logisch aber konsequent ist
das alles nicht wenn man darüber
nachdenkt und wahnsinnig einfallslos in
anderen ländern kann sich jeder
kostenlos testen lassen
in österreich werden selbst in schulen
verteilt und dafür haben wir in
deutschland jetzt eine ganz neue zahl
nichts mehr incidents 50 vergisst die 50
die 35 ist jetzt der neue heiße scheiß
ja ab 35 dürfen auch nicht friseure
vielleicht irgendwann wieder irgendwas
öffnen unter strengen auflagen und wenn
die 35 stabil ist wie viel tagen ist
seine 35 stabil
mindestens drei tage sage ich mal
irgendwas zwischen fünf und
oder 3 und 5 tagen ihnen sollte es sein
ein anderes also sie können mal davon
ausgehen mindestens drei tage nennen sie
irgendeine zahl zwischen 3 und 5 ist
eine aufgabe aus dem mathe abi von nrw
jenseits von friseuren verfolgt die
politik weiter den plan irgendwann einen
öffnungs plan zu planen oder so und
wieder wurde das alles ohne den
bundestag beschlossen wichtige
politische entscheidung das muss man
unseren jüngeren also im lockdown
aufgewachsenen zuschauern vielleicht
erklären wurden ja früher so getroffen
es gab eine gesetzesinitiative die wurde
im bundestag debattiert und nach
dreimaliger lesung verabschiedet dann
ging es von da in den bundesrat noch mal
debatte wenn die dass da auch abnicken
ging es weiter ins ein familienschloss
von diesem netten älteren herrn zur
unterschrift ja früher manchmal
langwierig aber nicht schlecht für dich
heute trifft sich frau merkel virtuell
mit 16 länderchefs zu fünf stunden
debatte beziehungsweise in einzelfällen
fünf stunden kann die kraft klar und
beschließt eine verordnung und die wir
dann noch am selben abend in der sendung
markus lanz von markus lanz ratifiziert
mit karl lauterbach als zeuge war der
immer da ist ja meine sicher dieses
dilemma für die politik muss man dazu
sagen lockerungs druck und gleichzeitig
droht die dritte welle die mutanten
welle und in einem rennen zwischen
unserer deutschen impfquote und der
britischen mutante würde ich mein geld
nicht unbedingt auf deutschland setzen
na ja wir sind insgesamt viel zu wenig
zu langsam beim auszahlen von corona
hilfen selbst beim daten erheben ein
jahr corona und nicht mal dass
infizierte zellen klappt ja wir haben
jetzt richtig gute nachrichten die vom
robert koch institut veröffentlichten
infektionszahlen die fallen nämlich
heute ungewöhnlich niedrig aus hoffnung
macht der blick auf die sinkenden zahlen
allerdings oder wochenende ja auch
weniger getestet als unter der woche das
muss man dazu sagen
allerdings liegen zu wochenbeginn
weniger daten vor allerdings gab es
heute wieder übermittlungsfehler und aus
sachsen anhalt zum beispiel kam da keine
zeit
warum nach einem jahr pandemie sollte es
doch möglich sein die zahlen auf dem die
ganze politik basiert an jedem wochentag
realistisch zu erheben was ist denn da
los
das müsste man ja fast verfilmen die
neue epische zwölf stunden trilogie von
peter jackson sonntag gemacht im
gesundheitsamt teil eins bis drei in
diesem schwer erträglichen film basiert
absolut nichts bis zum dramatischen
finale gegen fortschritt sonntagnacht im
gesundheitsamt
hier hört dich keiner schreien weil
keiner da ist ja wobei jetzt
ausdrücklich zur ehrenrettung der
gesundheitsämter der datenstau hat
mehrere ursachen ja manche ämter melden
nicht am wochenende
es wird aber auch weniger getestet und
jetzt aber mal zur wichtigsten frage wie
geht's weiter mit unseren schulen dazu
hat sich die runde am mittwoch auf
folgendes geeinigt jedes bundesland
macht was es will
super nicht mal eine für alle länder
verbindliche test strategie an schulen
wurde da beschlossen vorschlag
strategien wie zero kurven sind ja
schwer umsetzbar aber wie wäre es denn
mal mit zero föderalismus ernsthaft wir
sagen einfach der föderalismus macht
pause bis incidents 10 oder irgendwas
zwischen drei und fünf wirklich ein sieg
wäre ja nach corona wieder einführen den
föderalismus in manchen bundesländern
wurden die abi-prüfungen verschoben in
anderen nicht
ist doch schreiend ungerecht mal ganz
abgesehen von den kindern mit
förderbedarf die immer weiter
zurückfallen gibt's dazu irgendwelche
ideen es darf kein verlorenes schuljahr
werden sind wir müssen vielleicht mal
darüber nachdenken wie wir den kindern
jetzt wirklich ein schuljahr schenken um
echt zu entsprechen
viel besser statt ihr bleibt sitzen wir
schenken euch ein schuljahr
toll ich meine klar ist schulen öffnen
angesichts der mutanten ein risiko gar
keine frage
andererseits müssen kinder tatsächlich
auch mal andere kinder treffen sagen
psychologen
und wer bitte redet eigentlich über die
eltern wer redet über die eltern die
leiden auch unter homeschooling nervlich
beruflich seit fast einem jahr findet in
deutschland kaum noch regulärer
unterricht statt
was genau macht das mit mama und papa
die kollegin birte schneider ist mutter
und holmes cooleren der ersten stunde
wirte können sie noch ja ja ja um die
uhrzeit geht's jetzt schlafen die plagen
aber ich bereite natürlich schon den
unterricht für morgen vor
das ist nämlich das eigentliche problem
man verwandelt sich in das eine was man
nie werden wollte in eine lehrerin
stephan mann das bringt nimmt ihre show
in die klasse wenn du da hinter mir
umschließt wird es jetzt schon wieder
eine rauchen
man warte doch bitte auf die pause
[Musik]
jetzt kannste und nicht rennen auf dem
gang
meine güte ein mann ist gerade einen
ganz schwierigen alter
sie haben die pausenklingel bei sich zu
hause ja klar ich wollte ein
realistisches schule feeling
deswegen mache ich auch das klo gar
nicht mehr sauber mir war offenbar die
ganze zeit eine lehrerin steht jetzt
durch den scheiß lockt dann rauskommt
auch im alltag ich bin lehrerin einer
tour meine mitmenschen mensch vermisst
paketdienst wissen viele ja garnicht
hermes war ja in der antike nicht nur
der götterbote sondern auch der schubs
gott der reisenden unter helfen das ist
ganz klar die schwerkraft eine der vier
grundkräfte der physik furchtbar ich
hasse mich selbst und wer ist schuld ich
habe ein leben jetzt bin ich lehrerin
ich weiß gar nicht ob das hier wieder
aufhört selbst in den intimsten
situationen so schatz
der heutige geschlechtsverkehr wie
schätzt du dich selber ein
also ich sag mal der anfang war ganz gut
da hast du dir mühe gegeben ich finde
auch du hast dich im vergleich zum
letzten mal deutlich gebessert
du könntest hat den sex besser
strukturieren machte jedoch vorher eine
gliederung so kann es nicht weitergehen
also bis ostern halte ich das nicht mehr
durch gucken sie mal ich hab ich habe
plötzlich seine so eine lesebrille mit
so einem trage band keine ahnung wo dir
kommt ich habe sie nicht gekauft ich
schwöre die war einfach da oder hier
da sind so komisch court auf näher an
meinen ellbogen wo kommen die her
das weiß ich nicht helfen sie nie an
birte schneider vielen dank alles wird
gut liebe zuschauer kennen sie noch
diese alte stern rubrik was macht
eigentlich heute was macht eigentlich
die korona war
sie sollte doch unser wichtigstes tool
seien bei der kontakt nach verfolgung
tatsache ist aber heute wird die app von
fast allen politikern totgeschrieben
wirklich 18 uhr auf einsätze gegeben
da hilft nur noch aggressives marketing
dietmar wischmeyer macht's vor onkel
wischmeyer set laden
[Musik]
hallo willkommen den onkel wischmeyer
sap laden nur bei mir gibt's die super
günstigen app ladenhüter die keiner mehr
haben will
völlig sinnlose apps die bürotag aeppli
machten geräusch wie im büro tucker toll
oder
sonst kann die nichts also ideal fürs
home office ähnlich gescheitert die
korona waren es meine macht seit wochen
kein mucks mehr
und was wurde die letztes jahr noch
gefeiert von politik und telekom wir
haben mittlerweile genauso viele
follower wie die rolling stones also vor
dem interpretieren und sagen ja wir sind
ein rockstar mit der app und der
vergleich mit den stones passt super
denn die sind ja auch bald mit der
korona app können sie vor sich selbst
und allen anderen verheimlichen ob sie
infiziert sind
das nennt sich deutsche datenschutz und
soll garantieren dass nur facebook
clubhaus und alle porno versender ihre
persönlichen daten kennen und nicht etwa
das gesundheitsamt denn das könnte mit
denen ja regelrecht was sinnvolles
anfangen gott behüte die app ist im
grunde genommen eher lästig sie hilft
uns in der pandemie bekämpfung leider
überhaupt nicht
nein wegen nutzlosigkeit das kommt mir
jetzt zu negativ über 20 millionen euro
die entwicklung der app gekostet und
dafür gibt es gerade mal einen
schützenpanzer puma und der steht ja
auch nur nutzlos herum mit der krone app
auf ihrem smartphone den nichts anzeigt
wie lehnen die bundesregierung mitteilen
dass auch nix ist jedenfalls nicht so
schlimm dass dauernd einer gibt unsere
groko braucht kein hightech die hat noch
ganz andere asse im ärmel
denken sie etwa dran mit jedem tag wo
die sonne wieder ein bisschen höher
kommt ist die chance dass wird es auch
hinter uns lassen sehr viel besser wir
beten wieder die sonne an willkommen
zurück in der steinzeit zum schluss
empfehle ich noch meine persönliche
lieblings apps den vater zu deutsch fort
bewährter einfach rein furzen und den
furz von anderen usern bewerten lassen
komplett sinnlos aber nicht viel
schlechter als die korona wahrnimmt
gute nacht
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da